pour six galeries
c'est l'heure de plier bagage un départ
forcé pas le choix sa maison n'est plus
habitable
depuis qu'elle a été frappée par deux
roquettes du hamas las venas bichonner
ses cela dernière tombe sur ashkelon 11
heures seulement avant cessez-le-feu
l'état de dévastation de la maison
témoigne de la puissance de l'explosion
les murs sont éventrés les vitres
fracassées et ce qui n'a pas été
entièrement détruit et recouvert de suie
un miracle dans ces conditions que
personne n'était blessé car cigale et
son fils n'ont eu que quelques secondes
pour se mettre à l'abri
j'ai entendu boum toute l île c'était
comme s'il allait nous tomber dessus des
moyennes cigale ne comprends pas que
l'on puisse s y visé volontairement des
populations civiles
elle ne ressent pourtant pas de colère
mais plutôt ce profond désir de paix que
seuls peuvent connaître ce qu'ils ont vu
de trop près les conséquences de la
guerre made testeuses les femmes les
mères les soeurs nous voulons vivre en
paix est elle une vie normale ici et
là-bas des dépenses est bon à toutes les
mères de l'autre côté ce n'est pas nous
ajoute t'elle qui faisons les guerres au
cours des onze jours du conflit le hamas
a lancé pas moins de 4000 300 roquettes
en direction d'israël
si 90% d'entre elles ont été
interceptées par le dôme de fer
le système de défense israélien
plusieurs centaines sont quand même
passés au travers à ce qu'elle en
seulement 75 roquettes ont explosé au
sol chacune d'entre elle synonyme de vie
brisée dans cette maison frappée par une
roquette ou troisième jour du conflit
une personne est morte et une autre a
été blessée
déflagration si forte que toutes les
maisons du quartier ont été endommagés
heureusement elie voyons voisins étaient
cachés dans son abri en onze ans il a
vécu trois conflits du genre mais rien
d'aussi intense année adam cherche alors
il ne soit pas plus rose
la paix ne sait rien des chats long il
faut s'asseoir et discuter dit il
aujourd'hui
pendant trente ans mal rasé un avis qui
ne fait cependant pas l'unanimité dans
le sud d'israël beaucoup ne voient de
solutions que dans la force militaire
muriel rachel rami ne cache pas sa
colère
depuis que son immeuble a été touché par
une roquette tuant l'une de ses voisines
n'y a pas de dialogue possible avec des
gens qui n'ont qu'une idée en tête si tu
es du juge au crépuscule de ce quatrième
conflit en 13 ans l'horizon reste sombre
il faut dire que les optimistes dans la
région ont rarement eu raison ici jean
françois bélanger radio-canada ashkelon